got some more information about the
death of john chalice the actor from
only fools and horses his family have
released a statement he was best known
for playing that second-hand car dealer
boise in all only fools and horses there
he is for that
famous car behind him um his family have
said it is with heavy hearts that we
bring you such sad news our dear friend
daniel's john chalice has died
peacefully in his sleep after a long
battle with cancer he will always be
loved for being boise and leaves a great
legacy of work that will continue to
bring pleasure and smiles for many years
to come
please respect the privacy of his family
and friends at this difficult time and
be assured that in the future there will
be an occasion to celebrate john's life
when everyone will be welcome to come
along and the official only fools and
horses um twitter account
has tweeted and said that the family has
asked rather than sending flowers any
donations are sent to john's chosen
animal charities and if you look on that
tweet you can see there's
three charities there as boise says as
boise would have said
you know it makes sense